we can rejoice today to have
a clear position of the
european parliament which supports the balance between
private life and professional life in europe
what does that mean what does that mean that we
have obtained three types of leave three different types of
leave the first is  is
paternity leave then it is true that
many member states have
paternity leave
the question is to know
how long his paternity leave is
some member states do not have any and
especially the  way in which they are paid
and so we have effectively obtained that
there are two weeks of
paid paternity leave
and that is important there is parental leave
which is guaranteed to him non-
transferable, that is to say that we do not  does
n't happen from the father to the mother because
when you go from the father to the mother, well,
you reinforce the traditional models and
finally you have a new leave which is
the leave for carers, that is to say for
people who have to take care of  of a
family member who is  t in
difficulty who is a woman who is also in
difficulty with her health and therefore we have
obtained c3 c3 progress in terms
of workers' rights today to
better balance her private life and her professional life